let's talk about fury let's do it I fury
is a game that I knew nothing about
until I came in this morning and I was
like hey peak what you play in there so
it's free on PlayStation Network this
week for PSN PS Plus yeah 3 4
PlayStation Plus users I think $25
otherwise okay um well that's a that's a
real good deal for playstation plus sign
I guess yeah I think this is one of
those games that's priced may be higher
than most people are willing to accept
for what it is right i mean i think hope
you know we can talk about value all day
but anyway the game is free so if your
PlayStation Plus user I definitely
recommend you buying it don t see as
well dad on PC as well this game was
showing off at e3 two years ago as part
of sony's press conference and it's a
sort of like a neon like stylish like
cel-shaded twin stick shooter / bull
hill / swordplay game yeah talk about
the structure because I needed to like
watch you play to sort of understand how
exactly explain yeah it's like it's like
somewhere between a fighting game and
like a boss fight game it's all boss
fights okay there are sort of narrative
sections that tie your whole journey
together but essentially you are in a
circular arena against a boss you are a
guy that has a laser gun and a sword you
can dash you can pair your tax stuff
like that but these boss fights it's not
just like the boss has one health bar
the whole thing is defeating a boss in
different stages so we'll embossed may
have five or six stages but within those
stages of a battle there are too many
stages one which is sort of the the
long-range thing that's more like a
twin-stick shooter where you're dodging
bullets and you know trying to parry
attacks that you know the enemy is doing
up close when you will their health down
enough then it goes into this close
range swordplay thing and the camera
zooms in and it's really close and it's
all about pairing and dodging these
unblockable attacks in time and the game
the game is all about punishment both in
taking advantage of your enemy when they
slip up avoiding punishment when you
slip up because when you do the computer
really just kicks your ass and yeah like
you you have to put in like
20 minutes sometimes to beat these
battles and they're super hard they're
super hard yeah like you know you have
to be diligent at all times and if you
screw up it only takes a few hits for a
boss to basically put you on the brink
of death meanwhile you're spending like
15 minutes getting them close to her
eyes to where you're almost finished and
it's it's an aggravating game but it's
also it's very fair like it's difficult
on purpose and you have to be a glutton
for punishment kind of to appreciate it
or just really freaking good so how many
i guess like how long is it how many
like because you haven't beat me yet how
many bosses have you like come up
against five I think there are eight
total there's like one scene where they
show sort of like a series of planets
descending I think I counted eight I've
gotten through five at this point and is
it like is it like a single run where
you need to like kill them all in a row
without dying or like no saving in
between each fight yeah you saved in
between a fight um yeah butBut man like
I've spent hours on a single fight
before and it was always a sort of thing
where i get like eighty percent of where
I needed to be but then like something
would happen in that last twenty percent
either i wasn't i didn't know what to do
or i slipped up and like let frustration
get the better of me and then I had to
just start over and it's one of those
things where you're like do I want to
sit here for another 20 minutes and like
my head against the wall you kind of do
it's a really fast game that feels
really great when you succeed so are you
playing up because you feel like you
have to because you want to review it or
are you actually like going back because
you're enjoying it uh it's I'm Elizabeth
i mean i'm reviewing the game so i have
to beat it but i'm enjoying playing it
like it's there's something about it's
one of those things where you put it
down after being frustrated for a while
and you come back the next day and then
you're like oh man like this is what I
was missing yesterday like I'm feeling
pretty good now and that feeling is
great it's gratifying and it makes you
appreciate the game a little bit more so
I'm finding that the more I play it more
I love it cool man good stuff Mike you
interested in playing this bad boy doll
fury yeah i mean i hate the comparison
because it's kind of overused lately
like to ill effect a lot but our souls
yeah
I have to say cuz I've been wanting to
replay sorry again but I mean it seems
like something despite the fact that you
might be putting like you said 20 to 30
minutes into these boss fights from what
I saw the moment to moment gameplay
seemed satisfying and fun enough that I
would want to replay those bosses just
to beat them yeah yeah like I just
started replaying the earlier bosses
today to show you the game initially and
and it was fun like I having that
knowledge like gives you a different
perspective so it's yeah it's certainly
like something punishing like Dark Souls
like you have to be on point you have to
know you're doing I just have to say
that shot goop shoe said about a minute
ago waiting for someone to say Dark
Souls desk yes bingo thanks my kid I'll
throw it in there did you play
battlefield yeah it's pretty dark souls
asked but I mean like aesthetically it
seems appealing to me the fury and you
know yeah looks cool reminds me of El
Shaddai ascension Metatron voice yeah
probably reminds me that because you had
told me like last week but and that was
like the one thing I liked about El
Shaddai I don't really like the combat
but I liked how weird and kind of a
stylized it was so good that alone is
like the surface appeal is enough to
maybe draw me in at the very least yeah
if we're gonna make comparisons it's
like else should I hyper light drifter
and then yeah maybe something like Dark
Souls in terms of the underlying good
soundtrack difficulty so soundtrack is
amazing I had Mike sort of started
introduced me to his band carpenter brut
just last week and then I was looking
into fury and I was watching a trailer I
was like this not tracks pretty good so
I looked up the trailer and I was like
[ __ ] carpenter brut is on the soundtrack
it's it's great it's this genre called
outrun which I was not really that
familiar with before but it's it's sort
of like the the the neo-noir like techno
stuff of the 80s where you had like a
dark like sullen like lone person who's
trying to like persevere against
horrible odds it sounds like like /
debater style yeah exactly do out there
on the soundtrack okay like hardcore
upscale like are like up-tempo kavinsky
it feels like dr imagine drive on like
coke eyeballs i don't know but or you
know what I'm talking about or like he's
in like hobo with a shotgun it's that
girl like you you should watch that oh
man I spent a lot of the weekend playing
The Witcher 3 blood and wine which
starts off with three god damn boss
fights in a row oh yes I'm thinking
about this game which is like that was
traumatic enough as it is the boss
fights are really special right like
it's one of video games greatest
traditions yeah but usually the start of
game like this is relegated to like you
know you unlock a boss rush mode in a
game right or like Mega Man at the end
you'll fight the series of bosses but
it's rare we see a game that is only
boss fights right the shadow of the
colossus comes to mind yes punch out as
well or I feel like we're having the
same conversation we did this morning
but like every fighting game is almost
like a boss rush game totally but yeah
there's like this this real sense of
like you know it's it's a really potent
experience and and how you take it is
kind of defines whether you like her
this though I know you haven't updated
yeah but how about data how about that
doom boss flooded and yeah it's pretty
good yeah boss fights good stuff yeah
let's not talk about that I haven't
gotten there yeah complete do complete
them and then complete inside before the
internet ruins hands like that dude
that's really good i just i actually saw
the end and I didn't oven sighs yeah
Alex new house was playing it next to me
last week all right yeah I don't don't
don't look up don't look it up just play
the game it's real good anyway all right
that's enough when's the review going up
for free hopefully tomorrow I've been
sick like just in a puddle of my own
filth so I'm just right Nick trying to
pull myself out of that I'm 6 out of
that yeah I'm gonna try my ball shoot
we're going to see a movie tonight yeah
I'm stayin up we gonna see what our
Swiss Army sorry okay Paul Dano Daniel
Radcliffe and for those who want to know
it's a few or I not a few ry Frandsen
for anything about this game and it's
free like seriously play via playstation
4 and PlayStation Plus just play the
game yeah I mean all I can say yeah and
who doesn't have playstation plus one on
playstation 4 and some people people
don't play on my like this
hi